hi I'm Michelle and thanks also to all
the organizers and to the Samus
Institute for this wonderful setting and
opportunity
Alistair said yesterday at the start
that that they're interested in Cross
fertilizing teams and so on and this uh
year the Samus Institute is running
these two themes one on the present team
on real analysis whatever real means
and later on or they already started the
other theme on big data and the talk
today is going to be something that
attempts to straddle across these two
themes to take
concentration which is one of the
central Tools in in the theme on real
analysis and applications and and see
how it applies to this area and machine
learning which is an application to Big
Data to in particular to techniques
dealing with support Vector machines and
kernels
so
I'll start by reviewing the Johnson
Linden Strauss Lemma which is kind of
the mother of all concentration results
very classical and beautiful
and then
show that this is
our attempt to make the case that this
is making a strong comeback today in the
sense that there's a huge interest in
applications of this of these kinds of
ideas in in the area of machine learning
and Big Data
so the classical Johnson London Strauss
Lemma is the
if you have whoops
endpoints in high dimensional space so
the
capital D there which will stand for
Dimension is intentionally put us in
a large case because we are always going
to think of this is extremely high
dimension so this is the thing of
interest in machine learning
applications
so you have endpoints in extremely high
dimensional space and what the Johnson
linen Strauss Lemma allows us to do is
to project them into a much smaller
Dimension which is little K
and the projection of the property did
all interfere distances are preserved
approximately up to any desired accuracy
one plus minus Epsilon
the interesting thing is the projected
Dimension is independent of the original
Dimension and only depends on the number
of points and it's logarithmic in the
number of points
and this is known to be essentially
tight
but the results of alone
so the the original proof was to take a
random linear map which is an orthogonal
projection onto K dimensional Subspace
and then use measure concentration on
the sphere these the famous doretsky's
theorem
but by now today there are many more uh
there's a much simpler proofs Elementary
proofs and up to a number of people
wrote papers on this and
there's a very nice streamlined
presentation that we have today
yeah so that probably reflects why
people you know that that's but this is
how they did it originally I think I
think
so as I said the Johnson Industrials
Lemma makes is making a big comeback
today in the area of big data and has
found a lot lots of applications in many
different areas you know with proximity
problems
online data streaming problems
and you know slightly related different
area complex sensing so there are a
number of different areas currently
where these kinds of ideas of random
projections not to low dimensions are
playing a very Central role today
and today uh I'm only going to address
the applications in machine learning and
to one particular
sub area within it which is
and to the
use of Kernel methods and support Vector
machines
so just to recall the the way the
Johnson Linden straws Lemma has proved
well there is a what you do is you take
a random linear mapping
with these parameters and and that
random linear mapping has these
properties and this mapping is universal
and the projected Dimension only depends
on your Epsilon and Delta not on the
original dimension
and this mapping is uh sorry this
mapping is particularly simple so it's
just multiplication with the suitable
random Matrix m
and the The Matrix M has Dimension K by
D and the entries are gaussian IID
normal zero one so it can't possibly be
a simpler mapping than this and this one
has the
the the properties and the stated in the
statement of the Johnson Lemma
and the the distributional version so
this is stated by saying well if you
take a fixed point then the two Norm of
the fixed point is preserved up to
Epsilon by this random linear mapping
and this version of course implies the
other one by taking suitable choice of
parameters so it's in some another
another way it's a classic application
of the probabilistic method
okay so yeah
so that's the the basic simple
constructions I'm going to talk about
many variations of these of this
construction that are now needed for
applications to Big Data but before that
let me do a short primer on on support
Vector machines and and classification
by support Vector machines
so in in machine learning problems data
is represented by
typically quite often as high
dimensional vectors
and although the ambient Dimension can
be extremely high these vectors are
often extremely sparse
and so here are some examples so if
documents are represented as bags of
words then the vector corresponding to a
document is in the ith coordinate is the
number of occurrences of word eye in the
document
if it's user ratings then it's the
rating given by movie to a movie eye by
a particular user
on Netflix
and so in all these applications the the
ambient Dimension is extremely high but
the number of non-zero entries are are
very small so this is something to keep
in mind as we go along the ambient
Dimension is high but there are only a
very small number of non-zero
coordinates
and so the classification problem then
is that you're given so this is a
classification supervised learning
problem in machine learning so what you
have are n training examples
x i y i
so the X I are the data points
represented as these vectors these past
vectors in very high dimension and the
yis are are labels plus minus one say
binary classification
and the classifier is just a function
that Maps these vectors to minus one
plus one using and it's it's constructed
using the the given data as as a
training set
and I and the goal is to construct the
function which has nice properties in
the sense that if you want to classify a
new point then the probability of
misclassification should be minimized so
the the risk oops
and the risk of misclassification should
be minimized
so very uh
classical approach to this is to use
linear classifiers so the idea here is
to take a hyperplane
which is specified by this Vector w
and use the sign of this linear function
as the classifier
so this is perhaps the simplest approach
and this is
very common approach still today
now the problem is there can be many
different possible linear classifiers so
here's a simple example with a data set
where there are many different
classifiers which linear classifiers
which separate these two so amongst this
large class of possible classifiers here
which is the one one should pick
so the support Vector machine
methodology is to pick the linear
classifier the hyperplane which has the
largest margin and margin is as depicted
in this figure so here is the the line
that separates these two data points and
the margin is the distance between
the closest point in one set to the line
plus the closest point in the other set
to the line so some of those two things
and that's the margin of the classifier
I
said why you're assuming that the black
and white points belong to two sets
which are separated yeah so for
Simplicity let's assume that this is
indeed the case that there are really
two kinds of the the original data comes
from a distribution which has two very
widely separated classes so in a typical
application I mean you have a cancer
patient and a healthy patient and their
Gene microarray measurements for example
will be very different corresponding to
this very different doesn't mean
well they are not in general but just to
make it simple I showed them as really
cleanly separated like this of course in
reality it may not be cleanly separated
and that's another issue my second
question was you said that the samples
from an unknown distribution are you
assuming if you assume nothing about the
distribution then you can
yeah so if you want to prove a
statistical result then you need some
assumptions on the kind of distribution
that there are there are really two
separated classes and and you have
enough examples from both
but yours
you could think of two very separated
gaussians for example with very widely
separated means
if you if you want to think of the
statistical aspect so you have two
distributions which have uh
they are widely separated in in some way
and the classifier will try to find it
without without knowing what the
distribution is
so the approach is to find this linear
classifier which maximizes the distance
like this the margin between the two
sets of points so as pointed out in an
actual real practice it may not be so
cleanly separable that there are
extensions of this method to apply to
that kind of situation where the data
may not be cleanly separated but let's
not get into that let's stick to the
this is the the separable case so we'll
stick only to the separable case
so the formulation as an optimization
problem becomes
this
so the the goal of maximizing the margin
becomes this optimization problem it's
minimized the norm two Norm of this
Vector W subject to these constraints
which simply say that the two classes
are are separated correctly
and this is the famous svm formulation
so another way of formulating the same
thing the equivalent way of writing this
is to say is to think of it as as
finding the distance between the convex
cells of two sets of points so you have
two classes A and B and the support
Vector machine is actually finding the
distance between these two convex
polyhedra this is an equivalent way of
looking at the support Vector machine
formulation we kind of exploit this
later
now the standard Machinery of in
optimization you apply the LaGrange and
Duality you you get the dual formulation
in terms of these variables Alpha so
this is an equivalent just the Dual of
the
formulation that that I displayed on the
previous slide
and the optimization problem here this
is a quadratic optimization problem
this also gives you information about
the the oops about the structure of the
optimal solution W it is a linear
combination of the input points
so this is the reason for calling it
support Vector machine so they're
exactly these points that correspond to
non-zero coordinates in this dual
formulation Alpha
and being non-zero means you know with
the complementary slackness and so on
those in those constraints are satisfied
with equality
so this is uh the reason why these
things are called support Vector
machines
now another interesting thing to observe
here is that the separating hyperplane
has a nice explicit description and this
description only involves the dot
products of the original data points so
it's given explicitly by this formula
and the only thing that you need are X Y
transpose x x
so just the dot product between the
training set vectors and the new point
that you want to classify
so this is often written as this as a
function K and this K is what is in this
area called the kernel
so there's another a good point to keep
in mind that often in these support
Vector machine methods what you really
need are only these dot products
thank you now another nice feature of
support Vector machines is even though
the description as we saw before
involved a linear classifier it can be
used also as a non-linear classifier and
this happens when you take the original
points and project it into a very high
dimension so here's an example for
example so the green and the red points
are clearly separable but the separator
is not a linear
is not linear it's it's a non-linear
surface
but if you project these points into
some other space into a much higher
dimensional space than in the higher
dimensional space the classifier can be
constructed as a linear classifier
so there's a specific example here in
two Dimensions so if you take this this
example in two dimensions
and then this embedding into
three-dimensionals with x i squared X2
squared in these two coordinates since
and X1 x2 in the third coordinate this
project this embedding into higher
Dimension has the property that now
there is a linear classifier in this
three-dimensional space separating these
two points so this is another
interesting thing that you can take
something which is has only a non-linear
classifier in the original non-linear
separate in the original space and then
by embedding it into higher Dimension
you can actually achieve this linear
separation
so in the machine learning literature
this is called the kernel trick because
again to in order to do this in the
higher Dimension you only need the dot
products of the embedding you only need
Phi Phi XI transpose Phi XJ and so so
you only need these these dot products
and so the embedding is often only
represented implicitly via such a matrix
k
and there's a condition on when a matrix
K defines such an embedding it's the
condition is that this Matrix has to be
positive semi-definite
um
so here are some examples that are used
a lot in practice linear kernel
quadratic kernel polynomial kernel so
the basic message here is that often in
in this machine learning applications
data is not presented
need not be presented explicitly but
only via similarity via similarity
kernel so you only get this Matrix K
that measures in some way how these two
objects are similar then this is a
positive semi-definite Matrix and this
embedding that you need for these
methods is only implicit
and in some so in some cases so it may
be very high dimensional or even
infinite so here is a the radial basis
kernel
which is very popularly used in popular
applications and this this corresponds
this by the theorem you know that there
is an embedding corresponding to this
Matrix but this embedding is actually
infinite dimensional
so you do have cases where the the
similarity kernel is going to be not
only high dimension but can even be
infinite dimensional so this is another
thing that these methods have to deal
with so we're going to come back to this
at some point so in machine learning
things one of the two things it's
important to be able to work only with
kernel representations
but discolor representations May
correspond to high or even infinite
dimensional embeddings
so now if you take
so we are interested in in fast
algorithms to solve these problems they
have to scale to very large dimensions
so in a typical applications in Google
these days they consider data which is
million dimensional and billions of data
points and so on so it has to scale to
those kinds of numbers and so the
running time of these solvers is really
crucial
so there are many methods today
available for solving this optimization
problem for the support Vector machines
and here are the running times of some
of the most popular ones and you see
there's a dependence
on both n and D
in some cases but in other cases there's
a dependence only on D and not on N so
the last mentioned method is a
stochastic method and has
some interesting properties that it
doesn't really depend on and it only
depends on on the dimension but all of
them do depend on Dimension so
the dimension is a very important
parameter in these problems and so when
you have these very high dimensional
points and this is an issue so how do
you
cope with these very high Dimensions
when the running time it enters into the
running time in these in this way so
here is a direct first use of the
Johnson Linden Strauss idea if the
dimension is is an important thing one
can
so this is the first take so the most
direct take that you take the original
data points and you project them into
these into a very low dimension
preserving the margin so since the
Johnson Linden straws Landmark preserves
distances between points it's going to
preserve the margin of the classifier up
to one minus Epsilon Factor
so the first simple direct ideas is
project the original data points into a
low Dimension and then apply the svm
methods and then the running time the
dimension that appears at the running
time will be the lower the smaller
dimension
there's a so now
so this is pretty immediate but there is
a one needs to take some care here
because you have to take into account
the computation time now to do the
projection and if you do it naively this
is quite expensive so it's going to be
order K times D per data point
and so here the dimension enters the big
Dimension enters the picture here
so just doing the projection Lively is
going to be expensive
let's remember that the input data is
high dimensional but is often sparse so
the number of non-zero coordinates can
be much smaller than the total number of
Dimensions so the question is can we
exploit this in order to do the
projection much faster than than doing
this in the in the most straightforward
direct fashion
so there's been a lot of work in in that
direction in how to compute this
projection faster still retaining all
the nice properties of the Johnson
Linden storage Lemma a number of
different people got faster methods
and today I guess the best the state of
the art is the construction by Kanan
Nelson and they achieve a projection
into Dimension K which is optimal one
over Epsilon Square log one over Delta
and the important thing is that the
sparsity they have a very sparse Matrix
so now the Matrix that you construct the
projection with is not the original
Matrix where you had IID gaussian
entries the idea is to make the Matrix
much faster so you can compute the
projection faster and all these methods
where different ways of getting sparse
or matrices and the construction by K
Nelson is is the best one in this
direction today and the their
construction is the property that each
column has Atmos s given by 1 over
Epsilon Times log Del 1 over Delta
non-zero entries why is that better than
the um
um
better than the Woodruff
have this Varsity time I think it's
compatible it's uh
it's about the same
their construction is similar properties
but I think this was earlier
I mean this is early I thought Clarkson
was a little bit stronger here no I
don't think that I think this is the
parameters are roughly the same
so this has uh the projection time is
going to is going to be S and the
sparsity times the number of non-zero
entries in The Matrix so you do you get
the fast Computing of the projections
projection is given by just multiplying
the input X by matrix m
and that Matrix m
M okay and that Matrix has just IID
gaussian entries that was the original
and now the idea is just to make that
Matrix much faster still retaining all
the properties
now so this so Kane Nelson have this
construction but this construction has
so it's not as nice in terms of
it's not independent I mean it's a more
complicated Construction
and it presents a challenge to to
this community because well the the
construction involves dependent random
variables so there's no Independence
anymore and then if you want to get the
concentration results you need
concentration results which are able to
handle this dependence
so in the knesset paper they they they
they they do a lot of elaborate
calculations uh explicit elaborate and
massive calculations of higher moments
in order to get the concentration
results but it would be nice to do this
in a more
more uniform way which you can reuse
later because
doing these explicit computations has to
be redone every time you have to you
know change the application a little bit
you have to redo the the
computation of higher moments all over
again so question is there a way to
prove concentration for these kinds of
constructions in a unified fashion so to
adapt the concentration results when you
have kind of dependent variables you
have in the K Nelson Construction
so one way one approach that I
seems hopeful is that in fact this the
dependence that you get in that
construction is has some kind of
negative dependence property so this
so this was mentioned yesterday one of
the talks version of this
so this is a property called negative
association
so it's a strong negative dependence
condition the the prop the condition is
that if you take two non-decreasing
functions any arbitrary non-decreasing
functions f and g of disjoint sets of
these variables
then the correlation is is negative so
the expectation of the product is less
than the product for the expectations
for non-decreasing functions and
disjoint sets of variables
so the the K Nelson construction does
have this property and the the
coordinates of the projected Vector as
long as the vector is non-negative
coordinates so for the special case
they are negatively Associated and each
coordinate is sub gaussian so you do
recover the original
um
the concentration results of the
projection by exploiting this fact but
this only works for one of their
constructions and for a case when the
input Point has non-negative coordinates
so it would be interesting to
to see if it works in general or the
after Construction
okay so now I'd like to go to this so
this was the most direct application of
Johnson Linden Strauss Lemma now to a
Less Direct application
which is when the data is only given in
the form of similarity kernels there is
no Associated embed there's no embedding
you don't have the embedding to work
with so you can't apply the projection
directly so what happens in this case
okay how can you approach this problem
when the data is only given in this form
of the similarity kernel and not with
the explicit representation in high
dimensional space
so here there's an approach where what I
call LP type abstract optimization
problems that is very useful
so the idea goes back to random sampling
methods for linear programming and just
a very simple idea you take a random
sample of the constraints you solve the
LP on that random sample
keep the basis that determines the
optimum and now you look at the other
constraints and if some of the other
constraints are violated then you update
the basis with respect to the Violator
constraint and you continue until there
are no violated constraints so this is
the basic simple idea behind titles
linear time algorithm for linear
programming in small Dimensions which
initiated all this work
so it turns out that the same ideas are
applicable in a wider context not just
to the linear programming problem itself
so there are a bunch of other types of
problems for which the same kind of idea
a random sampling idea works
if you want to compute the smallest
enclosing ball of a set of points or
various other ellipsoids or annulus in
particular to this problem and that is
of interest to us today in this context
the distance between two convex
polyhedra this is the the svm problem
it turns out that the same that this
falls into the same class of problems
called the abstract LP type of problems
so what is common is that
all in all these problems the optimum
solution is determined by a small number
of input objects and this is called the
combinatorial dimension
the solution value is monotonic it only
increases or decreases if you add more
objects and there is a locality property
that if the solution increases or
decreases batting more input objects it
already does so by adding those objects
to a small the common total Dimension
number of objects in the bases
so the abstract framework for LP type
problems involves a fine a set finite
set Edge you can think of it in the lp
problem as the finite set of constraints
or in the svm problem as the points with
the labels
and then there is to each subset of H
there is a value
is a function W that assigns it to real
value and this function W has these two
properties it's monotonic and it has a
locality property so
if adding a point H to if you have two
sets f and g that have the same value
and adding a new Point H to one of the
sets increases the value then it also
increases the value for the other set
so and this is kind of very nice simple
setup
so this is all you need the common
abstraction from all these
different examples you just need this
common abstraction
and then you have what is called Okay so
so to solve the optimization problem you
need two Primitives you need a violation
test it does the value of the objective
function increase if you add a new point
and you need a basis update when you
find such a violation and want to update
the basis so as long as you have this
abstraction and you have these two
Primitives then you have a common
algorithm to solve all of these problems
this is the random sampling algorithm
for LP type problems and the idea is
very similar to the original random
sampling idea of soil
so you start with the random subset h of
of the original set h of size Delta you
you start with a null basis and you
update it to this set of points you
added you compute the violators and then
you you repeatedly choose a random
subset of points from the remaining you
add it to this basis you find the new
violators and you continue
so it's the same idea that you had in
the the original LP problem of societal
and you you just you can more or less
apply the same thing in this abstract
abstract framework
and the nice thing is that this you can
analyze the running time of this
algorithm exactly
and this was done the famous paper by
Mata Sheikh sharir and Wellsville and
the running time of the algorithm is n
times
two to the combinatorial dimension Delta
square root of the combinatorial
dimension Delta
so when when this Delta is small then
this is a linear time algorithm
so coming back to the svm so you can so
you can take this algorithm and apply it
to the svm problem and here
so here's where we use the fact that
this is the svm problem is is a problem
of this class it's about separating two
convex hyperplanes
and so the combinatorial dimension of
this is D plus 2
. so and you do have a violation and
basis updates from the svm Machinery you
do have you can Implement these two for
this problem
so applying this
algorithm to the svm problem so this is
just repeating that in the context of
svm you get an algorithm whose running
time is going to be
and the number of points to the 2 to the
square root of the dimension
so now here is the second application of
Johnson Linden's trans Lemma so as long
as you're you're willing to work in much
smaller with an approximate solution so
you you want a near optimal margin then
you can work so the the dimension
appears there as in the exponential it
appears as 2 to the square root d
so
by using the Johnson Lemma you can go to
a much smaller Dimension now and still
retain more or less the original margin
and the running time now becomes n to
the 2 to the square root log n log log n
so it's a little low of N squared and
the important thing is that to do this
you don't need the explicit projection
so all of this can be done with the data
represented only in the kernel form so
this is very important for SVA methods
so you get a algorithm for the svm
classification problem that only uses
the the kernel Matrix and not the
explicit projection so this LP type
algorithm that I mentioned does not need
the explicit representation
in the high dimensional space
um
okay so that was take two on using
Johnson linen Strauss with respect to
the for the classification problem it
gives you the running time which is
little of N squared the dimension has
disappeared
so now we go back to the primal
so there are a number of reasons why in
this
thing that we discussed just now the
Dual formulation and the using the
kernel Matrix K and so on is a bit
unsatisfactory today and one is that the
number of support vectors can grow
linearly in the training size and you
saw that earlier one of the svm methods
that I showed you
in the beginning had a running time that
did not depend on N just on the
dimension so
and that was something that used the
that solved the problem in the original
Primal formulation
so there have been a number of recent
advances in first order methods for
Primal problems reading leading to
extremely fast algorithms that scale to
very large problems and so what you want
to do really is even is again to go back
to that Primal formulation which uses
the explicit representation in euclidean
space so can you go back to that
that formulation
but the problem is you only have the
kernel so you have only the kernel
Matrix you don't have the explicit
representation but somehow you would
like to use the explicit representation
because you have all these fast methods
when you have the explicit
representation
and for some kernels the embedding is
actually is even infinite so how does
how can we do that
so again the idea of random sampling
so we know that if you have this kind of
Kernel this Mercer's theorem tells you
that there is a representation like this
the problem is this representation Phi
can be in very high high dimensional
space or even infinite so the the simple
random sampling idea is let's just take
random samples from this infinite high
or infinite representation so let's work
with
uh um
so let's approximate the kernel by
something which is an empirical estimate
of it formed by random sampling and this
random sampling will hopefully give us
not only a good approximation to the
current but it also gives now an
embedding that achieves this
approximation
so that's and the simple idea can we use
random sampling to get an explicit
representation which is a good
approximation and this is not going to
be always possible but it's possible at
least for some kernels which have
various kinds of symmetry properties
which can be used to get for example it
gives you one example if it's symmetry
the Symmetry with the symmetric group
then the Fourier basis gives you this
kind of infinite expansion
so there's a simple example where it
does work so the famous gaussian kernel
which is very commonly used in practice
this has the basis functions from the
Fourier expansion given explicitly like
this it's e to the imaginary eye
times the inner product of Z and X
and the kernel is just so this is just
the the integral representation that I
showed you before it's the expectation
of of this dot product with these basis
functions so you have a very explicit
representation for this particular
kernel so for these kinds of kernels and
this random sampling idea can be used
and so this was proposed by Ryan
indirect people in 2007.
so so that construction takes a random
Matrix Z
which is n times D with parameters n
the parameter n given uh
by that
that estimate 1 over Epsilon Square D
log 1 over Delta
so that gives you an approximation to
the RBF kernel in this form
and there's a concentration that the the
approximation is good
with with high probability and this is
just this application of the measure
concentration for lipsticks functions
with the gaussian measure
so this was proposed by rhyming direct
there's a nice properties and they
showed that actually works quite well in
practice as well
I don't know why they called it random
kitchen sinks no idea how they why they
called it that
so now so this is a nice thing they
showed it works but the problem with
this is again that
Computing these these things so this is
again uh you should again remind so this
construction should remind us again
about the original Johnson Linden straws
construction this is a random Matrix Z
multiplying the original Vector X
so and this is exactly the same kind of
construction and we'll have the same
problem namely in Computing this Matrix
Vector product is expensive
so can we do this faster
so this is a recent paper in the
icml this year like these are lotions
smaller where they give a faster
approximation of the kernel using a
different Matrix which is again sparse
has some sparsity properties and reduces
the multiplication time to do this
and for a special case of this and
they're able to prove a concentration
using the by adopting this gaussian
concentration of liquids functions
and it applies to also other types of
kernels not just the gaussian kernel I
showed you but
kernels in the same family
okay so uh this is faster but again one
might so the question natural question
one can ask is can you use the kind of
construction that you had in the K
Nelson construction and the uh that I
showed before which reduces the
multiplication time to the to even more
to the minimum possible sparsity times
the non-zero number of entries in The
Matrix can you get the same
concentration results using the K Nelson
construction so I believe that's this is
the case but again this is where you
need to prove those concentration the
presence presence of dependence so there
is a problem in trying to use
to salvage those concentration results
when you have the kind of dependence in
the K Nelson construction so so probably
what you want there I mean if you use
the structure results Alex kittens has
and combines with different parts and
Ultra Construction
McCain Nelson is a very complicated
construction yeah and don't look at the
clocks and we'll just look at the
extensions we're just boiled down to
matrix multiplication which is even
simpler analysis okay construction's the
same
is a much simpler construction if you
combine that with the structures also
added students has okay in the precise
form the answer is definitely
okay but you don't have all those
combinatorial defendants okay attacks
okay so you already solved one of the
problems I put up there
yeah so to conclude the Johnson Linden
Strauss and other related methods that
Woodruff and Clarkson Woodruff and other
types of methods these have lots of
applications in the machine learning
experiment kernel methods
and so these constructions and
concentration results should have even
further impact on applications in these
areas
so what I showed today was that the
three different ways you can do it one
is when you have the explicit uh
embedding then you can do a direct
projection use faster constructions of
the projection the second is when you
only have the kernel and you want to do
it implicitly then you can use the lp
type methods to just get
and you use the Johnson Lane installs
Lemma only to get the bound on the
margin but you don't actually do the
projection
and you use it in the lp type framework
and the third is yeah when you have the
kernel you want to approximate it
using random sampling and this is
Possible only for a few types of kernels
today maybe you can extend it to
a larger class of kernels that has more
applications in practice and here there
is a
there's there are many open problems in
in using concentration methods as well
as fast construction and trying to
combine them to get the best of both
worlds
thanks
any questions remarks
comments instead of linear classes
functions that's like
classifying using say so you classify
using a degree one binomial right using
a linear function equality so do they
use
for example
so the error that you want after the
projection or running approximate the
kernel doesn't it have to depend on the
number of samples or at least number of
support vectors in order for the
the
thing to make sense afterwards you're
assuming that the error is just Epsilon
but
Asylum should go through should should
be smaller as the number of samples
increases because you kind of have them
accumulated error there
right
whether you're thinking about the sub
statistical error with the large number
of which you go to zero as there are
more data points have to do more with
deviation
yeah I know but still when it
after you project when you take the
scattered product this Asylum
accumulates many times right
not really I mean so in this
construction there was no accumulation
of the Epsilon I mean you do the
projection of all the points and the
result because of because the Johnson
London stores it preserves the interfere
distances of all all pairs you have this
one I mean the margin is preserved to
one minus Epsilon
that's it I mean there's no accumulation
of the abstinence well but you don't
take the scatter product with just one
point
yes
for all of them at once
without a accumulation of Epsilon
questions